prepare for the blitz and to get
adjusted to the shorter time control
here we go anishgiri with the white
pieces yeah he has to strike first with
white it's a very quick uh opening it's
the catalan opening a variation of the
queen's gambit declined
these two have debated this uh or
similar variation earlier today
and uh this is well-known stuff black
temporarily went the pawn up white
regained the pawn but at the cost of
bringing the queen out early
don't try this at home white's queen
getting kicked around all over the place
but uh well-known stuff and this bishop
move
i think i've seen it before but maybe
not the most common
black again temporarily a pawn up but
black lagging behind a development the
black king's still stuck in the center
do you guys have much experience here
any side you favor at this early stage
i have zero experience with ivanka what
about i mean i i like being castled so
i'll pick white but that's about it for
me you vancouver yourself um
no i've had some experience with the
catalan but not necessarily in this
position
and i can see from the database that is
very rare only one game the the player
is actually following a game that was
played in may 25th between
daniel bogdan
diek and mustafa yomas so uh two strong
grand masters there
two very well prepared grandmasters
those two you mentioned there ivanka
known as opening experts these two as
well clearly opening experts
look at the clock times i mean we
thought they'd have to adjust to blitz
kind of slashing the time and uh they'd
have to kind of take a few moments here
and there but well david i mean
farouza was famous and the candidates
for
playing like a 10-hour session
or something so i mean he doesn't need
to adjust he he prefers blitz he's he's
the blitz king isn't he really saying he
was playing blitz and bullet chess until
5 6 a.m in the morning before a really
important game
but this is maybe bad news for anish
giri because of course with when you
start with the white pieces you kind of
want to launch the first surprise you
want your opponent to think to be caught
off guard and the fact that ali reza is
only now just thinking
it's and we're like 18 moves in yeah but
anish seems to be knowing what he's
doing and one extra minute on the clock
could be decisive a bit later um black
does have the bishop pair and an extra
pawn but that extra pawn could be
gobbled up right now it could disappear
uh in the center i'm expecting the white
queen or the white knight on the b3
square to go and capture black's pawn in
the middle
and
yeah this is typical kind of catalan
strategy white has this light-squared
bishop in front of his king that he
wants to keep forever and even not
having the two bishops it's not
necessarily uh a problem as long as
white can plant his knights on solid
squares in the center
this is the type of position that off
anderson a very
famous
famous swedish grandmaster would have
loved just taking that pawn back it's
kind of sitting there black's pawns on
the queen side on the left side they are
slightly weak slightly especially that b
pawn which is advanced
uh very far forward
it must be balanced though roughly
balanced it's pretty balanced also
because uh black's uh dark square bishop
isn't that effective either you know yes
as you mentioned like as the bishop pair
but not so many pieces on the board and
i agree with you it's a little bit
airy on the left side of the board and
uh
oh
anish asking questions already to that
bishop
yeah i mean it should step back i would
put it all the way back two squares
when in doubt push harry the h pawn
that's the motto and it's quite useful
in blitz just to kind of have uh pawn to
throw towards the enemy king some extra
breathing space for white's king as well
and the pawn has been regained
there is a threat maybe of white's queen
going all the way over and capturing
black spawn on the a7 square
and therefore ferocious offers a trade
of queens
to take or not to take that's the
question
what do you guys think um
i probably wouldn't rush to take um i i
maybe allow black to take me but i'm
thinking do i do i want to play the move
e4 or not is the first thing i'm
thinking
okay of course i'm wrong and he takes it
he gets the queens off that's an
interesting question simon because
black's knight in the center looks so
strong you could kick it away with the
pawn but i guess you do block in white's
light squared bishop so
very committal stuff
yeah it's it seems fairly even so far
i'd say there's not too much happening
here at the moment but anish
it kind of likes these kind of positions
generally as well doesn't he but how do
you get i mean the black knight seems
like a beast to me how do you get rid of
it i don't want to give up my bishop for
it
if i use my pawn it's not ideal pushing
that pawn and these
these structures wow i was going to say
one thing though i mean maybe if we
forget about that night in the center
and just kind of focus on that light
square bishop that black has doesn't
have too many squares
i mean we saw it develop to the edge of
the board
and
i can just see now that the rook can
perhaps come to the sixth row i'm just
kind of advocating playing around that
magnificent beast in the middle and
instead uh kick it back later on
black bishops do have some very nice
squares though black's dart squad bishop
can move
you love the bishops david don't you i
mean you you were gonna get a tattooed
you you'd take you'd take black here
wouldn't you
i'm not sure i'm more maybe more used to
these positions from uh the white side i
like to play these kind of catalans or
catalan-esque type of positions but
so david you mentioned yeah that's got
to be the bishops obviously you know
your great performance the olympiad and
you you play
these types of structures a lot uh the
catalan and uh
you know i was thinking maybe i should
try to play like david learn a bit how
how would i learn to play like you i
mean like obviously a bit of opening
food let's forget about that you said
old anderson should i study his games i
mean any any little tips for me study
anish geary's games uh if you want to
kind of play one of my heroes when i was
younger was vladimir kramnik and
he was the one who kind of taught me the
love of the catalan and
this kind of pawn structure with white
there are heroes out there in every
opening i guess
and just i was thinking about it i was
thinking hang on a second isn't this
like the english school of chess these
days because you have um mickey adams as
well as david luke shane they're all in
it for the long haul we'd like to grind
yeah like to grind and now ravi harrier
is coming through he's also
very good at uh massaging out those
small end game advantages maybe you've
inspired yeah it's definitely different
from the old english school of chess
where it was about kind of more direct
chess more attacking
i mean meanwhile the rooks have
disappeared so this one is
uh fizzling out slightly still a peace
imbalance black having the bishop player
white having the knights white having
the better pawn structure
and uh yeah simon i mean the way i
learned to play these types of end games
was going through games of off anderson
of vladimir kramnik of karpov
these end game players who seem to just
squeeze water out of a stone every time
and that's what anish needs to do here
it's a minimal advantage for white if
anything and he needs to take advantage
of the fact that maybe black double b
pawns
slightly weak so maybe people kind of
tend to forget that when they're when
they're trying to learn an opening day
they just concentrate on the first 15
moves and then they don't they stop you
know i mean that seems to be quite a
current trend but i mean i know
something i try to do in the chesapeake
courses i create is
have some model games of the players who
play it and look at what they do in the
middle game and i think this is
something that you've really got to do
you've got it you've got to study
experts and study what they do in the
middle part of the game because the
opening is just a way to get into
certain structures and i don't know
these structures so i'd like to see this
kind of position and how top players go
about playing it and learn strategies
that i can remember so i think that's is
so important so and off anderson believe
it was one of my favorite players which
people would not would not believe even
though i don't really
feel like twins
yeah yeah i don't really copy his ideas
but i appreciate them yeah so
fantastic player yeah and i mean you're
completely right there simon i mean
before my laptop died a couple of weeks
ago um i always have databases uh
there's always two databases on every
opening one is kind of the opening
theory where you have to just memorize
learn knuckle down and kind of
commit those to your understanding and
the other one is model games every
opening in the catalan especially
there's maybe two variations where
i've got anish giri a bunch of model
games by him
and he loves this type of pawn structure
normally he loves this type of position
where there's minimal risk for white now
just defending his knights both the
white knights on stable squares
he's really trying to target those two
black pawns on the queen side
yeah
and uh
so whilst uh anish is working hard at
trying to grind out this advantage you
kind of mentioned databases there and
one of my recent dilemmas is how how on
earth do i store this information do you
store it in lots of little databases
like for instance you mentioned these
in-game grinds i mean do you store this
like rook endings
or do you
kind of
and when it comes to openings as well do
you have like one specific
opening database i mean i guess it's
like when people study for exams at
school everyone organizes things
differently i mean
i've always been a bit disorganized with
the way i structure my opening notes
but yeah there's always been at least
one or two clear ways i always have one
database just with the notes just one
just with the model games where if i
need inspiration if i'm not in the mood
to memorize
that's what i go to
but uh yeah i know some people who have
dozens of different databases just for
one opening on different lines
you just have to label things where you
can find them
all the top players they talk about
opening notes too much
that's why i went back years ago and
just kind of organized everything and
then i realized i can't find them or i
can't find my opening notes
but meanwhile there's a big decision to
be made on the board and anish geary
he's frowning spending quite a lot of
time on this one that critical moment
and
the top players i guess they always
spend time even in blitz when there's a
capture and it's just weighing up the
pros and cons what do you guys think
bishop takes knight i should play it
yeah i'm with you ivanka i mean my first
thought is i i'd whip that off put my
knight in the center bring the king over
and then work then then have a think
which is probably the mistake right i
mean
keeping the tension is i don't know but
it looks obvious right if the black
knight gets one move if the black knight
moves away it's just going to be
opposite color bishops the knights will
balance each other out and it's going to
be a draw so anish if he wants to win
this game
and he has to try with white just take
that knight i still think there's
minimal risk you're not risking anything
really i mean you can put the white king
where the white knight is yeah
looks like a lovely square for the king
and you've got you've got a simple
winning plan as white if you do take the
knight
so to me taking the knight
to me also as a no-brainer but uh okay
he doesn't do it
maybe he was afraid of the black king
kind of
wandering around as well but you know
but here there's
let's see the night moves away and the
chance is gone
that's been the theme of venetia's
tournament against magnus on day one he
had opportunities he didn't take risks
at all uh when he had the opportunity
and there he could have just shattered
the black pawn structure black would
have had double pawns and an isolated
pawn in the center
worst comes to the west you just lock it
down as white you just kind of create a
blockade draw okay but this one's going
to be a draw anyway now
most likely
uh i guess he still wants to journey
over with the white king simon as you
mentioned
yeah okay still some chances maybe i'm
being too harsh on a niche but
but it's difficult actually because uh
the white king
can't just
wander over to the left and start
looking at some pawns because of course
you know black is also playing the game
and uh white also has some potentially
weak pawns on the right side i mean
just looking at the f2 pawn that is
going to be a target you need to have an
eye on that on the defense of that that
pawn
yeah i'm just worried because the white
king as soon as it starts running there
is risk involved right and the other
option
bishop takes night just a few moves ago
there was zero risk involved really
uh it also take i like this move by
black
it seems like white's pawns on the king
side are on the wrong colour kind of
because there are always going to be
targets to to black's pieces right fixed
on dart squares fix on dart squares i
mean this is the only
way you can try to cover a night jump
and now you've got to get your king
towards the queen side right but
i don't know it looks it looks like
black's holding
doing a good job of holding so far i
think anish is playing quite well i mean
i thought now was the chance to kind of
give a check and run with the king
but uh okay
instead he just took a safety first
approach and retreated the bishop i mean
still there is that uh that possibility
of the white king
taking oh no not anymore
okay now it's we're in the realms of the
dead dead
they can shake hands here can't they or
shake mouses or whatever they do
opposite color bishops no way forward
and we'll see the position repeat itself
anish missed opportunity again taking
the draw feels like that happens a lot